foreign
once I become debt free and cut up all
my credit cards will this hurt my credit
score lower credit scores mean higher
interest rates on the house I would like
to buy in the future or do you recommend
saving for a house with cash even though
that might take a long time this is a
great question because the credit score
industry is so confusing oh yeah and
they're very they keep it with lock and
key and so there are a few things we
know about how the credit score is made
up but yes canceling your card could
mean that your credit score takes a dip
yeah because that makes sense you pay
off your debt and close your accounts
and they go not okay with us well I mean
think about it the whole credit score is
based on your relationship with debt
right how much debt you have how long
have you had the debt you know what's
your debt to income we're like oh
yeah payment history is the biggest one
35 of your scores that's the factor
amounts owed is 30 length of credit
history another 15 new credit 10 credit
mix the variety of credit another 10
percent and so it's all having to do
with how much you play kissy face with
the bank man I'm not doing it I I'll be
the first to tell you guys when we
canceled our credit cards and the ones
that were in my name uh yeah my credit
score took a dip I'll be honest my
credit score was not great to begin with
it was probably like 6 30 or something
like that and yeah it went down and then
it had a period of time where it just
kind of stayed the same and did nothing
but let me tell you something George as
soon as that last debt was paid off it
went down to zero that's right so what
we're talking about here uh is not a
tanking of your credit score it means
your credit score becomes invisible or
indeterminable so six to 12 months after
you pay off all your debt you close all
those accounts six to 12 months later
that score disappears yeah and here's
the good news once you cut up your cards
and become completely debt free you're
not out of the woods you got to have a
fully funded emergency fund and start
saving up the down payment and so you
actually don't need uh the credit score
for that process if you go through
manual under yes come on and tell them
George so manual underwriting is a
little known fact I did a a quick clip
from the show went viral on social media
and people think oh I can get around the
system I have a terrible score but I can
still get a no score alone no no it's in
the name no score loan and church home
mortgage is the number one lender in the
country that does these yeah and so that
you know if you go through Churchill
Mortgage for an example and you want
manual underwriting you gotta have no
credit score at all to do these manual
underwriting no score loans
which means you're completely debt free
you've got to have a good down payment
you know let's say minimum 10 down and
you go you got to do the 15-year which I
know is crazy in today's culture it's
worth it but if you do those things hear
me say this you will have the same exact
interest rate as someone with excellent
credit that's and I verified this with
our friends at Churchill I've had
multiple discussions we ran numbers
where we actually showed people your
quotes for your mortgages yeah and they
found if you do 10 down on a 15-year
fixed with a good you know your your
numbers all check out your W-2s are
there your income is there yep you've
got proof of 12 months of rental history
verific verified by a landlord or even
your parents and you have other utility
bills you've been paying on time for 12
months your insurance premiums your cell
phone bills your utility bills all of
that counts towards this financial
picture yeah to where a real person says
you are approved for the mortgage at a
great rate and let me can I just say
because I know somebody regardless of
how well and how eloquently George just
described that they there's still
somebody sitting out there going
I don't know and can I just tell you I
was that person when Sam and I were
going through the baby steps you know we
were like there were some things that I
was like I know Dave is saying this I
know George and Rachel and all them are
saying this but can it really be true
I'm telling you I'm sitting in the seat
telling you it works credit score went
to zero and I was like oh I was excited
but I was a little bit nervous and then
I did what they told me to do we went to
Churchill Mortgage Jeff Green shout out
to Jeffrey green at Churchill Mortgage
he walked us through the process and
here's the thing it's even easier if
you've got like a standard nine to five
job because it's easy to show you know
all the records and everything they want
to show but as a small business owner it
still worked the proof is in the pudding
I'm sitting here telling you and I've
done the same I went through this
process and the crazy part is people
still commented going BS and I went what
part of this do you not understand what
I just told you I did it and then here's
the frustrating part Jade people start
pop it in the comments going well yeah
look at that guy's skin color of course
he got approved for a mortgage what
what so Jay can you verify uh look look
the melanin is real and your girl's got
a house and she got it on a zero credit
score now here's the thing why do you
want to be right so bad that's what I
want to know why do you want to be right
that you cannot buy a home with a zero
credit score what is that getting you
what is it getting you I kind of like
the fact that we live in a world where
you don't have to bow down to the credit
gods and there's still a way for you to
make a way without borrowing money from
credit why are you mad about that I'm
mad y'all got me mad we got a riled up
it's so true Jade we can Rise Above This
broken system yes and people just go
because they've never done it and
because there's so much baggage there's
so much shame there's so much crap that
they've had to deal with financially
they just go well that might work for
them but it's not going to work for me
but what's crazy about our plan is it
works every time you work it and when
you become completely debt free with an
emergency fund and you're patient you
save up that down payment you make the
sacrifices you need to make you can
become a homeowner without a score yeah
regardless of your skin color and where
you came from and all the baggage that
you come to the door with you can win
financially but it starts when you put
all that baggage aside and say I'm gonna
win in spite of all that boom George and
here's the thing here's the thing if you
want to play with debt if you want to go
and do the credit card deal so you want
to do the credit card shuffle you want
to play with assets and liabilities and
leverage and do go ahead and go on and
do that and get yourself a 800 credit
score and go buy your house and have
trouble sleeping at night but for the
rest of us as for me and my house as for
me in my house we are not going to serve
these FICO Gods we are not going to do
it we are going to have our own money
and our own account doing our own thing
and if you want to be mad about it you
go ahead and be mad all day because
we're going to be laughing all the way
to the bank and we ain't mad about it
that's right we want to share the good
news so and with this credit score stuff
even aside from home ownership people go
well Jade your insurance rates are going
to be terrible and how are you going to
rent a car and a hotel listen I have
lived my life without the credit score
using a debit card yep and I even
checked I checked every major rental car
companies policies they all have a debit
card policy yes they do and yes you
might have a slight slightly higher
deposit yeah you got to have a little
money in your account but aside from
that it wasn't much different than a
normal process no and the same goes for
pretty much everything renting you know
renting an Airbnb getting a hotel yeah
uh and car loans that's a big one people
say well Jade how am I going to get a
car loan you don't you don't get it you
pay cash even fraud you know people have
said well you got to have a credit card
what if you have fraud I'm like well
number one I got Xander to cover that
and two anytime I've ever had fraud on
my account they get they've given me the
money back it's the same thing you don't
need credit cards that's a lie I'm done
with those questions come at me FICO
come at me bro that's what I'm talking
about when it comes to credit George and
Jade warshaw are not playing George
Campbell and Jade warshaw we do not have
the same last name hashtag debitlife I
know that's right we got that debt free
lifestyle and we want that for you as
well this is the Ramsay show